local now 5 42 oh my goodness holy cow
oh wow we're celebrating national donut
day this morning doughnuts
we sent ron futrell to take the donut
challenge at some of the valley's most
popular donut shops
this one's near my house john you love
this place
joining us now from the spot that bears
his name ronald's donuts in chinatown hi
ron yum
oh see we can't hear him no but he
should be serving donuts here we're at
spring mountain road okay so in
chinatown area is where we're at
ronald's been around since 1971 ronald's
donuts the owner ronald is no longer
alive but billy who is the
son of the owner is going to join us
here in a minute i want to mention real
quick national donut day started in 1938
this history is going to impress your
neighbors and friends when you tell them
started in 1938
to honor the donut girls who during
world war one so
20 years before that were handing out
donuts on the front lines to help the
troops defeat germany at the time and
and the u.s troops were given donuts at
the time so it's to honor them they were
called donut girls at the time in the
salvation army uh started in 1938 but
okay here at ronald's donuts
billy what's the best donut i should try
over here what do you think
can i just grab one myself is that okay
one up right here
okay
okay we're going to try the fritter here
in a little bit um ronald jonas you got
you got billy give me one second here
okay i know you're busy today nationally
did you know it was national donut day
yes i did sir okay
you better know it's national donut day
okay the fritters uh what if what do
people like about the fritters it's very
sweet like apple you like apple you love
it
what do you got do you make do you make
the donuts too billy are you no uh we we
actually have a bakery where she makes
donuts
make some every day whatnot and for me
i'm still like to learn how to make
actually
you'll learn come on your mom owns some
oh you got customers coming in you got
to you've got to go to work billy's got
to go to work but this is what we got
here we got i'm going to eat the rest of
the spreader here in a moment um
i was on a no sugar no grain diet in sng
it's called
i'm busting it now the diet's done today
okay i'm gonna go after all the donut
places i'm going to i'm going to go to
the gym
a little bit later oh by the way
who are these
oh he's busy
heather he said these are for heather
that i'm bringing these donuts back for
it's my favorite thought yes what do you
think you got ronald's donuts coming
your way heather
they're so good you're okay with that i
absolutely love ronald's donuts
all right but i'm worried about your
glucose levels ron
i'm not i'm getting blood work done
later today don't tell my doctor
this is a favorite for kids back in the
day from clark high school would come
here to this donut place because clark
high school's just down the road yeah so
they would come here and i used to work
just well years ago at another well we
won't talk about that a whole lot but it
was right around the corner from here
too all right so you're well well versed
in the ways of ronald's donuts ron and i
were both over there and ron and i would
both go over there we'll remember that
place yes exactly
all right uh and and so we'd come to
ronald's donuts here quite often yeah
well we're touring all over the valley
we're going to a different place next
where are we at next armando i think
it's glazed donuts okay that's where
we're going to next so stay tuned i got
to get on the road i'm going to try to
obey all the traffic laws and get there
in time for our next hit and have some
more donuts i'm buzzed so that's pretty
good
thank you yeah good luck ron you'll see
ron driving around thanks ryan we'll see
ron driving around because he'll just be
like this stack of donuts i know in his
car he may need a little protein powder
sugar coming out of his exhaust pipe
yeah i just had a giant cinnamon roll
right in front of him oh my gosh that
place is excellent that's a fritter by
the way if ron is frittering his time
away yeah a lot of great local donut
shops in town it's not just the chains
the local ones and pop shops as well i
think our photographers are just as
excited as ron about their their job
today right all right 546. uh